Друзі, всім привіт!
Щоранку натщесерце я п’ю склянку води.
У Бонні питна вода іде з крана.
Давайте простежимо, до якого джерела
ведуть труби від цього крана,
і розкриємо секрет чистоти німецької водопровідної води.
Водопровідні труби з будинку, де я мешкаю,
ведуть під річку Рейн, потім на іншому березі
піднімаються до водосховища за містом Зігбург.
Довжина маршруту – 25 кілометрів.
Водосховище Ванбахталь. От звідси насправді я п’ю воду щоранку.
Звідси також отримують воду триста тисяч мешканців Бонна
і ще півмільйона людей з Рейнського регіону.
Якщо бути точнішим, частка води
з водосховища у питній воді з крана - 30 відсотків,
решта 70 відсотків - це ґрунтові води зі свердловин.
Довжина водосховища - майже 6 кілометрів.
Тут 41 мільярд літрів води.
Керівник асоціації "Водосховище Ванбахталь" Норберт Екшлаґ
запрошує оцінити масштаби і відшвартовує човна.
Це заповідна зона з джерелами чистої води - Вассершутцґебіт.
Захист території водосховища,
ґрунтових вод, земель і лісів навколо регулюється спеціальним законом.
Окрім працівників водосховища,
ніхто не має права тут плавати на човні.
Для відвідувачів заповідника прокладені піші маршрути.
Кілька коротших маршрутів утворюють
один довгий піший шлях навколо водосховища
довжиною приблизно 25 кілометрів.
Підйом у найвищій точці пагорбів
сягає тисячі метрів над рівнем моря.
Під час інтерв’ю злітають збентежені мотором човна птахи.
Заповідник - ідеальне місце для життя 143 видів птахів і 18 видів риб.
Норберт Екшлаґ наголошує: чим менше людина втручатиметься в цю екосистему,
то чистішою тут буде вода.
За словами директора, тут можна навіть рибалити.
Однак черга з рибалок розписана на чотири роки вперед.
За рік тут можуть рибалити 150 людей.
Тих, хто рибалить нелегально, вистежує Андрей.
Штраф за нелегальне риболовство у Німеччині сягає півтори тисячі євро.
Ці люди ловлять рибу без дозволу,
який адміністрація водосховища видає на рік.
- І скільки рибалок-нелегалів потрапляють на тиждень?
- Може, десь двоє на місяць.
Натреноване око інспектора вихоплює дві фігури на березі.
Вони без снастей, тож пливемо далі.
Норберт Екшлаґ каже, що закон захисту водоохоронної системи
має чіткі приписи щодо ведення господарської діяльності
навколо водосховища і свердловин ґрунтових вод.
Далі він показує нам прилеглі сільськогосподарські угіддя.
За законом, місцеві фермери
в кооперації з керівництвом водосховища вирішують,
чим вони обробляють ґрунт і рослини, бо в підсумку
це все потрапляє у підземні і наземні води.
Навіть екологічні добрива - коров’ячий гній -
не розсипають по поверхні,
а вносять у ґрунт ін’єкційним способом,
щоб дощ не змив гній у водосховище,
або щоб з нього не випарувався аміак в атмосферу.
Для цього придбали ось такий агрегат за 440 тисяч євро.
- Приблизно з 2010 року ми працюємо на цій машині,
вона в нас вже третя.
Система працює цілком автоматично
на так званому автопілоті.
Всі наші машини зв’язані по Джі Пі Ес.
Гній подається на глибину 15-20 сантиметрів.
А ця сівалка дозволяє обробляти ґрунт без плугу
шляхом прямого засівання, щоб запобігти ерозії ґрунту.
Завдяки цьому дощова вода
просочується через ґрунт до підземних вод,
а не стікає по схилу, несучи все з полів у водосховище.
За допомогою от таких машин фермери
регулярно беруть проби землі на концентрацію фосфору і нітратів.
У лабораторії водосховища проби роблять
10 тисяч разів на рік.
Це - станція очистки води.
З першого погляду подумав, що потрапив у санаторій:
просторі будівлі і зелень навколо.
Те, що це не так, розумієш лише всередині,
коли бачиш вражаючі інженерні споруди.
Ось сюди надходить сира вода із водосховища.
Це близько 3600 кубічних метрів на годину.
І тоді ми додаємо хімікати.
Перший етап - очищення сирої води від хімічних речовин,
тих самих сільськогосподарських добрив
або залишків ліків методом коагуляції.
До води додається коагулянт - в даному випадку сіль заліза,
що утворює мікрозгустки, до яких налипають
забруднюючі речовини.
Другий крок - фільтрація через кварцевий пісок і антрацит.
- Ось ми бачимо: водопровід має різні фарби.
Зелений означає, що це труби із сирою водою,
а от там позаду - блакитні.
Це вже труби із питною водою.
Третій етап - деактивація шкідливих мікроорганізмів.
Перманганат калію вбиває планктон,
а діоксид хлору знищує бактерії групи кишкової палички.
В Німеччині вже кілька десятиліть для дезінфекції питної води
використовують діоксид хлору замість хлору -
достатньо його невеликої концентрації,
а побічні продукти від діоксиду хлору менш небезпечні.
Фінальна станція очистки хлор-діоксидом
нагадує космічний корабель,
а змішувач виглядає, як фантастичний реактор.
Четвертий крок - додавання вапняної води -
відбувається саме у цьому змішувачі.
Ґрунтові води, як і води з водосховища, мають
частково агресивний показник кислотності PH.
Така вода може роз’їдати бетон і спричинити корозію водопроводу.
Тож до неї додають вапняну воду,
щоб досягти більш нейтральних показників.
Зі змішувача вода потрапляє до споживача.
Ось цією синьою трубою
діаметром один метр в напрямку Бонна подається
120 тисяч кубічних метрів чистої води щодоби.
Смакує аналогічно, як у крані вдома.
Ціна тисячі літрів питної води
від асоціації "Водосховище Ванбахталь" - 60 євроцентів.
У Бонні вже фірми постачальники продають її за ціною
від 1,20 до 1,60 євро за тисячу літрів.
В середньому німці витрачають до 140 літрів води на людину за добу.
Це високий показник при тому, що вода постійно дорожчає.
Запитаємо в родини Гоффманн,
як вони ставляться до ідеї заощаджувати воду.
Мене зустрічає фрау Гоффманн з однорічною донькою Лоттою.
Зараз у Бонні спека,
тож ранок починається з поливу рослин у саду.
Це діжка для збору дощової води.
Вона з'єднана з водостічною трубою.
Тож вода під час дощу накопичується у діжці.
Коли перша діжка повна і літо у розпалі,
ми під'єднуємо і другу діжку.
У Юлії троє дітей.
У дитячому садочку та у школі їх вчать,
як економити воду під час чищення зубів та інших хатніх справ.
За рік родина Гоффманн споживає 143 кубічних метри води,
за які сплачує 370 євро.
Мені щастить з водяною темою - цікава деталь:
прямо біля будинку фрау Гоффманн розташований бювет із водою -
на ньому табличка - вода не для пиття.
Однак я поспілкувався з місцевим жителем і він сказав,
що п'є цю воду вже 80 років, а місто Бонн повісило цю табличку для того,
щоб убезпечити себе від можливих судових позовів.
Склад і властивості питної води регулюються у Німеччині
спеціальними директивами - Трінквассерферорднунг.
Для того щоб люди могли пити воду з цього бювету,
її б мали привести до стану, описаного у директивах.
Тож, за законом, табличка є -
значить, всі п'ють на свій страх і ризик.
А за природним законом кругообігу води - якість сирої води,
з якої потім отримують питну,
досягається також і завдяки ретельному очищенню стічних вод.
Їду на станцію переробки каналізаційних відходів,
яка знаходиться за 13 кілометрів від мого будинку, прямо на березі Рейну.
Друзі, я прибув на одну з чотирьох станцій переробки
каналізаційних відходів у Бонні.
У мене знов виникають космічні асоціації.
Подивіться, ну хіба не нагадує ця куля астрономічну обсерваторію?
Насправді там накопичують газ метан
під час процесу бродіння каналізаційних відходів.
А ось ця споруда, яка нагадує летючу тарілку,
накопичує концентрований бруд від каналізаційних відходів.
До цієї станції очистки стікає вся дощова вода з вулиць Бонна,
а також каналізаційні відходи.
По цих чорних трубах тиском витягують смердюче повітря від колекторів,
де стоки розділяються на рідку і тверду фракції.
Все герметично закрито, і не відчуваєш жодних запахів.
Інженери в накрохмалених сорочках водять мене порожніми залами без людей -
всі процеси автоматизовані.
Величезну станцію обслуговують п'ятеро працівників.
Це другий етап очистки, під час якого відсівається пісок, маленькі мінерали і камінці.
А коли ми підійдемо поближче,
то побачимо, що  туди нагнітається повітря
і завдяки створенню водоворотів можна відділити жири та олію.
В цьому ще одному безлюдному залі зі стоків вилучають папір, ганчір'я і поліетилен.
Далі після фази механічного очищення, іде хімічна очистка коагулянтами -
ідентична процесу, який я бачив вже на станції обробки питної води.
Останній етап відбувається у тих двох великих  резервуарах.
Аналогічні резервуари можна побачити майже у всіх очисних станціях Німеччини.
На їхнє дно після додавання коагулянтів, бо це ж хімічне очищення,
випадає осад з мертвих бактерій і фосфатів.
Далі осад, який виглядає як слиз,
перекачують до цих двох бетонних пірамідальних веж -
для краси засипаних землею і засаджених травою.
В них протягом 20 днів осад перегниває.
Метан, що виділяється, відкачують до кулеподібного резервуару.
Після перегнивання осад вже виглядає, як використана кава з кавоварки,
і його конвеєрною стрічкою подають на спалення у цей цех під склом.
Для спалення використовується газ, отриманий раніше з цих же відходів.
Метану вистачає на вироблення електроенергії та опалення приміщень усієї станції.
З попелу, що залишився, отримують фосфор для продажі у країни,
де дозволене використання фосфорних добрив.
А це контрольна кімната, де в онлайн-режимі датчики контролюють
якість очищеної води, яка зливається у річку Рейн.
Окремий щоденний контроль якості води здійснюють працівники хімічної лабораторії.
Повний цикл перетворення каналізаційних стоків на чисту воду триває 24 години.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що вам би ще хотілося знати про Німеччину,
і я обов'язково про це розповім у наступних серіях.
До зустрічі!